ricky martin celebrates a victory
against the nephew who accused him of
incest
plus the rap queens inspiring east ray's
new series and you know they're the
biggest female rap duo since like salt
and pepper
[Music]
beyonce reveals new clues about her
upcoming album e.t is with the stars of
dungeons and dragons at san diego
comic-con the way that i've been
describing it i think it's like i think
it's game of thrones
with princess bride
with a little bit of spinal tap eg's
download starts right now
we begin with international superstar
ricky martin who is speaking out after a
major legal victory in his restraining
order case it's case closed after
ricky's nephew withdrew allegations of
harassment and a romantic relationship
with the singer
it has been so painful it has been
devastating for me for my family for my
friends
i don't wish upon anybody
ricky's legal team issued this statement
reading in part the accuser confirmed
the court that his decision to dismiss
the matter was his alone without any
outside influence or pressure this was
never anything more than a troubled
individual making false allegations with
absolutely nothing to substantiate them
he may realize that either he doesn't
have a case or he realizes that he's not
being truthful and therefore wants to
kind of stop before it goes any further
so ricky was hit with the restraining
order in puerto rico earlier this month
amid claims he carried on a seven-month
affair with his nephew who alleged he
was the target of physical and
psychological attacks when trying to
break things off to the person that was
claiming
this
nonsense i
i wish him the best
and i wish he finds the help so he can
start a new life
ricky attended today's court hearing via
zoom but was never required to speak and
he posted the statement from his legal
team writing truth prevails
all right let's turn now to issa rae who
just scored her third acting emmy
nomination for insecure i joined her on
the red carpet of her newest project to
talk about those accolades and what's
next
i mean it must feel real good to get
that kind of recognition for the final
season yeah oh yeah it felt good you
know we aired in december usually people
forget about shows so i was not even
counting on it so it was a really
welcome surprise but it's no surprise
that e.t was with issa in 2016 before
insecure premiered and before her it
girl status was in full effect your show
kind of your story is coming to hbo you
must be really excited i'm beyond
excited like it's just the time yeah and
you know what you kind of made your name
in the in that digital space and and on
the internet how did you find that do it
going that route instead of really kind
of doing the tradition it was an
accident in that like i was already on
the internet i love social media and
then
you know i started putting content out
there people were responding and then it
grew and it grew beyond me and then you
know hbo called yeah and now look at you
look at you now
here i am
who's stressed not you who are the best
it's you
six years and 14 emmy nominations later
esa signed a five-year deal with hbo max
worth a reported 40 million dollars i'm
over the moon right now with the
potential it's so cool to have a
playground and at this point i'm just
making the stuff that i want to see like
what you know are stories that haven't
been told that i'm craving one of those
could be an insecure spin-off i've been
illuminating for a while but i haven't
like sat down to put pen to paper but
you know i want people to miss the show
and i don't want it to be like she just
finished
and another her new comedy series rapish
on hbo max which shows the journey of
two aspiring female rappers trying to
make it in the age of social media
this could change our lives gonna be
some private jets some lobster
this show is like an amalgamation that's
inspired by like all the female rappers
right now that are out with from cardi
to megan it's obviously city girls and
you know they're the biggest female rap
duo since like salt and pepper and it
doesn't happen overnight folks all right
it don't happen overnight
and listen it didn't happen overnight
for beyonce either and today she's
leaving a trail of breadcrumbs as we
count down to the release of her highly
anticipated album renaissance out july
29th and you know what she's counting
down with us she shared the track list
for the new album on instagram and
here's everything we know so far it
includes 16 songs with titles like
america has a problem church girl alien
superstar and thick oh yeah we are
expecting to dance through most of this
album especially after the
editor-in-chief of british vogue told us
that when he heard it the soaring vocals
and fierce beats transported him back to
the clubs of his youth
[Music]
last month bay dropped her first single
off the album the 90s inspired dance
record break my soul she penned the
summer jam with husband jay-z and new
orleans big balance artist big frida
she tells me how she's grateful for me
being a part of this track and i'm like
no i'm grateful for you calling me so
another great moment getting to hang out
with her
at the studio space
and um
i you know i needed an asthma pump once
i left out of the building another
artist who adores queen bee is lizzo
she's on the cover of the september
issue of l.u.k out july 29th wrapped up
in balenciaga tape it's the same look
kim kardashian famously wore to paris
fashion week back in march now lizzo
shared this funny look behind the scenes
feeling fussy walking in my valencia
seas trying to bring out the fat loss
she tried it she tried it it doesn't
have to be
wrapping you in valencia good luck i bet
i could do it all right inside the mag
lizzo says beyonce inspired her because
her projects often include a teachable
moment and reveals that she first saw b
after skipping school to go to an album
signing event adding every time i hear
her it's like man i want to make people
feel this way you know one thing that
lizzo is still waiting on a photo with
her
last year she posted a birthday tribute
to the queen with this snap saying she'd
keep posting it until they're able to
take a real one together moving on to
the breakup we didn't see coming he
melted me he melted me
somebody had to do it right for the
first time since her split from joe coy
chelsea handler is opening up in a
tearful conversation with glennon doyle
on her podcast we can do hard things i'm
okay i mean i feel you know uh
optimistic about the future now i've
changed so much
and i've loved my love was like so big
that it just blew me open
and as painful as the ending of
something like that is
i'm
i'm so
well-versed in
therapy and understanding that every
door shutting is a new beginning
man we've all been there and you just
feel for her hearing that pain you know
chelsea and joe met 18 years ago i
imagine how hard this is for her and you
know things were taken out of the friend
zone after reconnecting during the
pandemic they started going to therapy
together and chelsea says she knew it
was time to split when she felt like she
was losing herself joe shared this week
that he and chelsea were will remain
friends and he's her biggest fan as for
a possible reconciliation i still
believe that you know my person is
coming and whether that is jo coy in if
you know at a certain time or if it's
not i don't have any time for anything
other than excellent
all right moving on now is it the summer
of love for drake he was spotted living
that yacht life with a beachy brunette
in san tropez and now the rumors are
swirling
which got us wondering who is this
mystery woman and how long has she been
yacht-hopping with drizzy did they
define the relationship you know here at
the download we love to get down to the
evidence so this is et investigates all
right let's start with the woman at the
center of the speculation a source tells
e.t she's model and social media star
suede brooks which tracks because she
posted this instagram story of a
santropay gift shop earlier this week
now the 21 year old recently showed off
her love for the grammy winner on tick
tock calling this one of the best verses
[Music]
we did a deep dive on miss suede and
here's what we uncovered she rose to
fame the old-fashioned way on youtube
rise and shine
hi guys welcome back to my channel it's
suede she's also a model but maybe not
by drake's standards don't tell me that
you matter if you ain't been involved
and this isn't their first time hanging
out apparently they have a lot of
friends in common but how serious are
they well our source says they're having
fun together they are sweet whispering
in each other's ears and laughing i mean
who wouldn't be having a yeah
okay
but the pair spent time on land too in
case you're wondering they were seen
here having lunch at a restaurant with
some friends so what do their inner
circles think well our sources spill in
the tea on that too telling us their
friends think they make a cute couple
and have been rooting for them to hang
out more so what's next for this jet
setting pair we have no idea
drake posted plenty of pictures from his
lavish vacation though but no sign of
suede in any of the photo dumps so we
know they aren't instagram official at
least not yet look at those receipts
like pbs coming in well listen also on
an exotic vacay tristan thompson and
while he and chloe await their second
child together she can't seem to escape
his drama
i always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people earlier this week the reality
star liked a fan account's post of
tristan and a mystery woman strolling
hand in hand in greece it is what it is
so what's with the double tap it's just
i think a little too toxic for me to
keep reliving stuff like that she seems
to be supporting the caption that says
chloe and tristan are both single i'm
not here to play games our source adds
that nope they're not a couple she
doesn't care about the videos and photos
circulating and they don't speak unless
they're co-parenting their daughter true
he's a really hands-on dad and so it's
just easy to co-parent with him
i think we both grow together it just
makes our family and our bonds better i
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style as for how tristan and chloe plan
to move forward with a new baby on the
way via surrogate i just want to live my
life and be happy our source says chloe
is refusing to let any negativity take
away from her and her family's joy about
this exciting new addition i'm focused
on work and like taking care of me my
body and soul and true
meanwhile this guy comedian lil rel
howery is looking out for chloe he threw
some shade her baby daddy's way during a
chat with olympic snowboard champ chloe
kim at last night's espys give her chloe
kill me out
right
chloe let me tell you this chloe kim i
knew you was gonna be successful you
know why because you have two kardashian
names
in your name
the only advice i can give you watch out
for them tristan's that's all i got to
say
yeah i said it y'all thinking it
i was thinking all right dancing with
the stars phase maxim schmiarkovsky and
peter murgatroyd were at the espys 2.
and they've been working on growing
their family to give their son shy a
sibling and kevin frazier got a baby
update you guys have been very open and
honest about your ivf journey how's it
going it's going really well i was a
skeptic to the openness of it and how
open do we want to be and now i realize
that there is the reason why people do
struggle with it is because it's such a
taboo to talk we're very excited we're
kind of in the last stages of it so um
you know there should be
fingers crossed a pregnancy pretty soon
meanwhile max's brother val and his wife
jenna johnson are expecting right now
and jenna's bump was on full display
last night get this she doesn't want to
stop working in the ballroom though will
you dance this fall while pregnant
you know what i i gave him the option
i'm down give me someone give me an old
guy i'll do it i think safety wise it's
best i don't
but
my mind is like oh yeah i could do it
all right from sports to the big screen
a new full-length trailer for don't
worry darling is here and y'all it is
intense
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
[Music]
i was here when you got here
yeah
you sleep in the bedroom
directed by olivia wilde the film stars
florence pugh and harry styles who is
olivia's real life leading man too of
course the steamy thriller is how they
met and fell in love it hits theaters
september 23rd but before that the cast
will say ciao to the venice film
festival which is where ben and jen 2.0
made their red carpet debut so will
olivia and harry follow suit fingers
crossed
now here in the states san diego
comic-con is well underway a lot of big
tv and movie news is expected to come
out of that event for more on that let's
bring in wilmar fuji yes guys
that's right comic-con is kicking off
for the first time in three years in
person wow dungeons and dragons is
kicking the weekend off it's based on
the classic role-playing game and the
trailer just dropped right after the
panel we didn't mean to unleash the
greatest evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
now matt cohen is down in san diego and
talked with the cast about what we can
expect it's a lot of fun and the whole
thing about dnd is
it's really about joy you know it's just
about uh creativity and having fun and i
played with my family and had the best
time i had in years and so it's nice to
share that kind of vibe with the with
the community there are famous faces
that love this diesel wow
he's a total dungeon he's the most
famous dungeon master
in a
strange time right now and this film is
all about
fun the way that i've been describing it
i think it's like i think it's game of
thrones okay with princess bride
with a little bit of spinal tap hey i'm
just sold on that one it looks good it
looks good it
speaking of game of thrones on saturday
hbo will host a panel with the cast of
the upcoming house of the dragon which
also just dropped its first full-length
trailer they consider the mata urgent
that of your succession
who else would have a claim the
firstborn child
brenera no queen has ever sat the iron
throne
the king has an heir damon targaryen
i will not be made to choose between my
brother and my daughter now here's what
we know about the show it takes place
200 years before the mother of dragons
fought to reclaim the iron throne for
house targaryen also known as the house
of the dragon the 10 episode series
premieres august 21st and i actually had
a chance to chat with star matt smith
back in march we sort of look in
really on on one family's
trials and tribulations
um the targaryens and they're they're a
pretty crazy family i have to say
oh it looks so so exciting it looks so
sick so tomorrow we're going to stick
with the the fantasy theme here we're
going to get a look at the lord of the
rings the rings of power we're going to
talk to the cast tomorrow in the
meantime make sure you guys keep tabs on
et online for all things breaking comic
con news thanks you're welcome guys
time to talk music royalty she's already
got an oscar and five grammys and now
her is becoming a princess she's just
been tapped a star in abc's beauty and
the beast a hybrid animated slash live
action special she'll be making her
story playing belle december 15th it's
the first time actually an afro-filipino
woman has been cast in the role you know
her is a very busy lady she's also
starring in the upcoming color purple
musical remake acting has been one of
those things that i've wanted to do for
a really long time and i felt like this
was the perfect place to start it's
going to be very unexpected and it's
going to be really fun in the cast i
mean it's an amazing cast it's now being
in the mix with oprah right exactly i
mean it's it's this legacy is insane the
movie was oprah's big break and earned
her an oscar nomination in 1986. she's
also producing the upcoming remake that
also stars fantasia burrino danielle
brooks taraji p henson and another
disney princess the new little mermaid
halle bailey what does it mean to be a
part of that cast in this story i mean
it's historic because you know we grew
up watching the color purple i'm just
grateful to be a part of it it's magical
that's the only way i can put it all
right someone alerts lady whistle down
because we have some big bridgerton news
season 3 filming is officially
coming in
let's go
netflix released this behind the scenes
clip of the cast now we know the next
chapter in this series will focus on
penelope and colin bridger chin's
romance et's lauren zema talked to star
nicola coughlin about what that means
following season two's explosive ending
i feel like she's made some mistakes as
sort of an outsider i look at her and go
come on you lied a lot to your friend
you know you're lying to colin um i
think we're going to find her in maybe a
little bit of a bitter place the
beginning of season three
well someone who's not bitter actor and
director jordan peele whose new thriller
nope hits theaters tomorrow still ahead
a look back at how the comedian became a
household name in horror i'm dedicating
my life you hear me
to uh
putting out crazy crazy weird horror
films and chaos ensues when kevin hart
and the rock take on the tortilla
challenge he takes the download we'll be
right back
[Music]
you guys watching it
i know something's gonna happen
never i mean i've never heard you curse
oh man what did you jump this is why i
have trust issues well on wednesday's
tonight's show jimmy fallon tried to
spook daniel kaluuya 2 with the jump
scare challenge but as you can tell he
barely budged until this happened
[Applause]
oh that is too good and you know daniel
has quickly become a scream king he
stars and nope out friday but it
actually isn't his first trip into the
twisted mind of jordan peele
get out
sorry man okay
get out
yo
[ __ ] get out the house
the movie is
is made for anyone who's ever gone to a
horror movie and wanted to just be like
what you doing there
why are you still there call the [ __ ]
[ __ ] call the cops
it's for that person
that's you that's me rose
bros
bro
script and the film is that it's
paranoia i mean you know are they being
um
[Music]
oh
nope nope nope nope i'm out i'm out
it was jordan peel's directorial debut
this whole idea came from
am i wanting to make
my favorite movie that doesn't exist yet
and after writing more than 200 drafts
the oscar goes to
jordan peel
get out
i stopped writing this movie about 20
times because i thought it was
impossible i thought it wasn't gonna
work but i kept coming back to it
because i knew if someone let me make
this movie that people would hear it and
people would see it is it true that you
saw get out five times in one month yeah
he's so talented so funny so cool he was
someone i admired from kianpio
okay okay and i was like oh i would kill
to work with him
lupita nyong'o got her shot not once but
twice playing adelaide and her evil
doppelganger in us
and then
there was us trust me when she's dressed
as red you do not want to come in and
give her a note
no she said she looks julian
excuse me
whenever i start a film i am
my worst enemy and my critic in my head
oh she is
she is powerful she knows how to freak
me out these are my my nightmares my
fears put in here and and i want us to
look within ourselves so this is about
communal reflection it's about us so how
are you your own worst enemy i am my own
worst enemy in a lifelong addiction to
nerds and skittles
add scary movies to the list i'm
dedicating my life you hear me
to putting out crazy crazy weird horror
films
[Music]
listen jordan peele gets me to go see
scary movies in the theaters not me i
know well listen tick tock's tortilla
challenge slaps even harder when kevin
hart and the rock get in on the fun take
a look
knock me out
don't use your hand here we go
um
[Music]
[Music]
so i will
oh
it's too good obviously we had to get in
on the bus we only got one tortilla so
let's see who's about to get slapped in
the face ready
rock paper scissors shoot
are you ready all right now you're gonna
take that i get this keep us young kids
okay
did it just hit you
so bad again
oh my god join us right here tomorrow
with a new face and a new episode of
et's the download bye
[Music]